* Sanfte, dynamische Klänge *
Noch vor Sonnenaufgang herrscht
auf der Seychellen-Insel D'Arros
emsiges Treiben.
Die Haiforscherin Ornella Weideli
will früh zum nahegelegenen Atoll
hinausfahren,
um Jungtiere aufzuspüren.
Eigentlich ist das normal.
Wir sind relativ oft so früh los,
weil es auch wunderschön ist
und nicht so heiss.
Wir gehen auch früh ins Bett.
Daher habe ich
keine Probleme mit Aufstehen.
Jetzt haben wir hier die Flut,
die sehr hoch ist.
Normalerweise
ist das Wasser dort hinten.
Das brauchen wir, um an
einen anderen Ort fischen zu gehen.
Da kommen wir nur hin,
wenn Flut ist. Daher ist es perfekt.
Und doch wird die Fahrt
ein Wettlauf mit der Zeit.
Denn auf der Insel Paul,
am Rande des Saint-Joseph-Atolls,
zieht sich die Flut
schon bald zurück.
Das Problem ist nicht
das Hineinkommen wegen der Flut.
Paul ist höllengut,
wenn man bei hoher Flut dort ist.
Aber jetzt ist es wohl
schon wieder zu spät.
Die Befürchtung bewahrheitet sich.
Jetzt sind wir leider
schon wieder viel zu spät.
Die Flut ist schon draussen.
Und jetzt?
Das sehen wir jetzt dann.
Man weiss wirklich nie,
was genau passiert, aber ja.
Die Sandbank versperrt uns den Weg.
Wir versuchen es
vielleicht besser da drüben.
Stress im Paradies.
Einfach nichts.
Darnsley, bleibst du hier
und Ryan dort?
Der lokale Mitarbeiter
Darnsley Simara und Ornella
hoffen auf junge Zitronen-
und Schwarzspitzenriffhaie.
Diese werden mit einem Chip versehen,
dessen Daten Aufschluss
über deren Lebensweise gibt.
Normalerweise haben wir hier drin
sehr, sehr viele
Schwarzspitzenriffhaie,
aber die Flut
war heute Morgen um 5 Uhr,
und wir waren erst um 7 Uhr hier.
Das ist zu spät.
Und eben, teilweise warten wir
3, 4, 5 Std. und haben nichts.
Manchmal haben wir
innerhalb von 10 Min. 20.
Es ist immer
ein wenig eine Lotterie.
Und ich glaube, heute verlieren wir
diese Lotterie. Leider
Aber das ist die Natur,
da kann man nichts machen.
Sollen wir mal
ganz nach vorne gehen?
Ornella will die Haie schützen,
denn sie existieren
seit 400 Mio. Jahren.
Der Mensch hat sie in wenigen
Jahrzehnten beinahe ausgerottet.
That way, yes.
Die Angst, die wir Menschen
vor den Haien haben,
ist völlig absurd, denn die Haie
sollten Angst vor uns haben.
Wir töten so viele Haie,
laut Schätzungen
70-100 Mio. Haie pro Jahr.
Und Leute, die von Haien angegriffen
oder getötet wurden,
waren fünf - gerechnet
über die letzten paar Jahre.
Und das ist ja nichts,
wenn man bedenkt,
wie viele Menschen
täglich im Meer baden, surfen ...
Daher ist es traurig.
Die Haie sind sehr bedroht.
Sie werden von grossen Fischerbooten
als Beifang gefangen.
Es gibt viele Fische,
die man gut essen kann.
Das ist kein Problem, die
pflanzen sich schnell wieder fort.
Aber einige Haie haben
Fortpflanzungsmethoden wie wir.
Sie pflanzen sich
nur einmal im Jahr fort.
Z.T. eins, zwei, drei Jungtiere,
das ist ja nichts.
Es ist klar, dass wir
den Bestand so stark beschädigen.
Das stimmt einen schon nachdenklich.
Jetzt haben wir gerade
einen kleinen Rochen im Netz.
Bei den Rochen muss man aufpassen,
man kann sie nicht einfach ...
Also die können eben stechen.
So ein Stich
kann sehr schmerzhaft sein.
Aber eigentlich sind Stachelrochen
friedliche Tiere,
die sich nur verteidigen,
wenn sie sich bedroht fühlen.
Kein Junghai weit und breit.
Seit vier Jahren sammelt Ornella
auf den Seychellen Daten.
Aber heute hat sie kein Glück.
Es ist z.T. auch frustrierend.
Man macht alles bereit -
wir standen heute um 5.15 Uhr auf,
sie beide waren bereit,
das Material ist bereit -,
und dann gibt es einfach nichts.
Aber auch hier: Man muss alles in
einem grösseren Zusammenhang sehen.
Jetzt haben wir bereits
über 700 Haie gefangen,
an einem Ort, an dem noch nie
jemand Haie gefangen hat. Ja.
Sollen wir weiter?
Ja, wir haben die Flut verpasst,
lass uns abbrechen.
Sollen wir zum Boot rüber?
- Ja.
* Sanfte Klänge *
If you don't mind ... Thank you.
Würde Ornella
Stachelrochen erforschen,
wäre der heutige Tag
ein Highlight gewesen.
Tja.
* Sanfte, abenteuerliche Klänge *
Rochen gibt es auch im indonesischen
Tauchparadies Raja Ampat.
Mantarochen.
Umweltlehrer Jonas Müller
will den Kindern diese imposanten
Meeresbewohner näherbringen.
Dieser Mantaposten
soll sicherstellen,
dass nicht zu viele Touristen
abtauchen und die Mantas vertreiben.
(Indonesisch) Warum wurde
dieser Posten hier errichtet?
Weil es hier viele Mantas gibt.
Ja, es gibt viele Mantas. Und?
Damit die Mantas geschützt werden.
Ja, darum wurde dieser Posten hier
errichtet.
Jetzt gibt es eine Regel,
dass nur maximal 20 Taucher
oder Schnorchelnde
gleichzeitig im Wasser sein dürfen.
Sie wissen sehr wenig
über diese Tiere.
Ich möchte ihnen
dieses Wissen vermitteln,
ihnen auch aufzeigen,
dass diese Tiere wundervoll
und nicht gefährlich sind.
Ich gehe das mit ihnen durch -
wie geht man richtig
mit diesen Tieren um?
Es hat sich bewährt:
Sobald sie merken,
wie wundervoll diese Tiere sind
veim Schnorcheln, ist die Angst weg.
Mantas
sind bei Tauchtouristen beliebt,
aber ihr Ansturm
schlägt die Tiere in die Flucht.
Darum wurde der Zugang limitiert.
Es ist grundsätzlich
ein gutes Modell,
wenn es
noch häufiger angewendet würde.
Es ist ein Pioniermodell.
In Raja Ampat müsste man
diverse Tauchspots so machen.
Mantarochen und Haie stehen
in diesem marinen Park unter Schutz.
Die Touristen müssen für den Eintritt
umgerechnet 70 Fr. bezahlen,
die dem Umweltschutz
zugutekommen sollen.
Ein Mantarochen würde niemals
in euch reinschwimmen.
Er stoppt immer rechtzeitig.
Jagt ihn nicht, sondern wartet,
dann kommt er ganz nah ran.
Jeder von euch kriegt
so einen Block und einen Stift.
Damit kann man
unter Wasser schreiben.
Keine Sorge, es hat genug für alle.
Die Kinder haben
mit diesen Slades auch die Aufgabe,
zu schauen, welche Mantas sie sehen.
Also welche Spezies -
ist es ein Riff-
oder ein Riesenmanta?
Welches Geschlecht hat der Manta,
männlich oder weiblich?
Hat der Manta Verletzungen?
Sie schreiben alles auf und
achten drauf, was der Manta macht.
Ist er am essen?
Lässt er sich reinigen?
Versuchen zu beobachten, was der
Manta macht, das ist ihre Aufgabe.
Ich hoffe, es hat auch Mantas da.
Mal sehen, ob wir Glück haben.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Einfach nichts.
Auf den Seychellen
hat Ornella Weideli
die Hoffnung auf junge Haie
noch nicht aufgegeben.
Ein einziger Zitronenhai.
There.
- I know.
Mein Geschrei
hat ihn wohl erschreckt.
Ryan Daly ist der lokale
wissenschaftliche Leiter
der Schweizer Stiftung Save Our Seas.
Diese finanziert
Ornellas Forschung mit.
* Jauchzer *
Gut gemacht! Was ist es?
Ein neuer Zitronenhai.
Wie du rennst, Wahnsinn.
Als Ryan anfing, den Haien
nachzurennen, dachten wir alle:
"Ja, ja,
er erwischt ja eh nie einen."
Und jetzt ist es so weit,
dass wir sagen können:
"Ryan, renn!", und zu 99 %
bringt er einen zurück.
Das Jungtier wird gemessen,
gechippt und gewogen.
Das Gute bei dieser Methode ist,
dass sie nicht
in ein Netz schwimmen,
die Kiemen
verfangen sich also nicht.
Der Stressfaktor für den Hai
ist relativ klein.
56,2.
Ein ausgewachsener Zitronenhai
kann über 3 m lang
und bis zu 180 kg schwer werden.
Diese zwei Haiarten
werden lebendig geboren,
aber sie sind danach
auf sich selbst gestellt.
Wenn wir an Säugetiere denken -
die werden auch lebendig geboren.
Ob nun Tier oder Mensch -
sie werden von der Mutter
gepflegt, gefüttert,
die Eltern sorgen für sie.
Diese Haie werden auch lebendig
geboren, aber niemand hilft ihnen.
Sprich, sie müssen innerhalb
kurzer Zeit lernen, selber zu essen,
was nicht sehr einfach ist.
Das finde ich sehr spannend.
Wenn Ornella
einen Hai ein zweites Mal fängt,
kann sie Rückschlüsse
auf dessen Lebensweise, Nahrung
und Bewegungsradius ziehen.
In Raja Ampat freuen sich die Kinder
auf die Mantarochen,
gleichzeitig haben sie aber
auch Respekt vor ihnen.
* Sanfte, abenteuerliche Klänge *
Doch erst einmal
sichten sie viel Plastik.
Aus dem Unterricht von Jonas wissen
sie, dass die Tiere ihn fressen,
weil sie ihn für Plankton halten,
und daran eingehen können.
Also sammeln die Kinder ihn ein.
Weiter unten
ist das Zuhause der Mantarochen.
Schnell legen die Kinder
ihre Scheu ab.
Im wohl exotischsten Klassenzimmer
der Welt haben sie die Gelegenheit,
die wunderbaren Tiere zu beobachten.
Und die Fragen zu beantworten.
Nach dieser positiven Erfahrung
werden sie die Mantas
künftig mit anderen Augen sehen.
* Sanfte, abenteuerliche Klänge *
* Dynamische Klänge *
Auf den Seychellen
sorgen Delfine für Hochstimmung.
* Jubel *
Mit dem Tempo des Bootes
können sie locker mithalten.
* Dynamische Klänge *
Das Team von Ornella Weideli
versucht sein Glück nun
mit grünen Meeresschildkröten.
Die Reihe ist an Ryan Daly,
dem lokalen wissenschaftlichen Leiter
der Stiftung Save Our Seas.
Entwischt.
Da ist noch eine, direkt vor dir.
Siehst du sie?
Yeah.
Weil wir keine Haie
gefangen haben,
gehen wir weiter
zum nächsten Projekt.
Wir haben alles dabei,
um Schildkröten zu fangen.
Sprich, Ryan steht nun
auf dem Bug des Bootes,
sucht grüne Meeresschildkröten.
Darnsley koordiniert.
Er sagt ihm, wo, wie, was,
und Darnsley manövriert hier durch.
Klingt einfach ...
Zu schnell.
... ist aber ziemlich schwierig.
Sie ahnte, da kommt was.
(Lachend) So schwierig.
Ich habe nur einmal eine erwischt.
Es hat viel Schatten,
ich springe noch mal.
Yes!
Er hat sie.
Eine grüne Meeresschildkröte.
Sie wurde noch nicht markiert.
Wir bringen sie jetzt zum Ufer,
um sie zu vermessen.
Vorsicht, sie schlägt aus!
Leg sie kopfvoran vor dich hin!
Wir beobachten die brütenden Tiere.
Die sind am einfachsten,
weil sie an Land kommen.
Über die jungen Schildkröten
wissen wir weniger,
die sind schwieriger zu fangen.
Darum fangen wir sie so.
Sie sind ein wichtiger Teil
der Schildkrötenpopulation,
über die wir nicht viel wissen.
Das Saint-Joseph-Atoll
ist sehr wichtig für die Futtersuche
und den Schutz der Tiere.
Schon vor vielen Jahren
wurde auf den Seychellen
ein Schutzprojekt
für Meeresschildkröten eingerichtet.
Ist das Datenblatt hier drin?
Ja, da drin.
Okay.
Die grüne Meeresschildkröte
stammt von der Landschildkröte ab
und existiert seit 225 Mio. Jahren.
Sie atmen Luft.
Sie müssen nicht unter Wasser sein.
Ihnen ist auch
über Wasser sehr wohl.
Benutzt du dieses Ding?
Wir brauchen das kleinere.
Das hier?
- Ja.
Kannst du es sehen, Darnsley?
9.94.
- 9.94.
Wir markieren die Schildkröten.
Wenn wir sie erneut fangen, gibt uns
das Hinweise über die Anzahl Tiere.
Tschüss, hoffentlich auf bald!
Wir fangen kaum je
eine Schildkröte zweimal.
Das bedeutet, es gibt hier
eine grosse Population.
Man schätzt, dass ungefähr
2'000 grüne Meeresschildkröten
im Saint-Joseph-Atoll leben.
Auch für die erwachsenen Tiere
ist es wichtig,
weil sie an den Stränden hier
Eier ablegen.
Es gibt nicht viele Orte,
an denen wir
erwachsene, nistende Tiere
und gleichzeitig Jungtiere haben,
die hier leben.
Es ist ein einzigartiger Platz
für grüne Meeresschildkröten
im Indischen Ozean.
Der Schutz der Tiere und der Umwelt.
Das ist der Kern
von Ornella Weidelis Arbeit.
Und es ist auch
zu ihrer Lebenshaltung geworden.
Ich glaube,
eine der Lösungen ist bestimmt,
dass einfach jeder
etwas Kleines macht.
Ich z.B. fliege sehr viel
und ich weiss,
dass das nicht gut ist
für den ökologischen Fussabdruck.
Aber wenn jeder das ändert,
was er kann,
dann gehen wir alle
einen Schritt vorwärts.
Man kann nicht alles radikal ändern.
Ich kann nicht aufhören, zu reisen.
Das gehört zu meiner Arbeit.
Aber ich kann z.B.
bei meiner Ernährung schauen,
die schränke ich sehr ein.
Wenn jeder Mensch etwas einschränkt,
führt das wohl zum Ziel.
* Sanfte, abenteuerliche Klänge *
Am Mantaspot in Raja Ampat
geniessen Jonas und die Kinder
den Freiluft-Unterricht.
Die grossen Mantarochen haben sie
aus nächster Nähe beobachtet,
und sie haben gelernt:
Es sind freundliche Tiere.
Wir hatten drei Mantas,
viele Taucher,
aber auch viel Abfall leider.
Aber es war bestimmt
eine coole Erfahrung für die Kids,
mit den Mantas zusammen
zu schnorcheln.
Sie sind sehr begeistert davon, ja.
Das haben wir
beim Schnorcheln rausgeholt,
und das ist natürlich genau ...
Die Mantas ernähren sich dort unten.
Der Plastik
löst sich in Mikroplastik auf,
und sie werden das dann
fälschlicherweise auch essen.
Der Ausflug
beinhaltet nachhaltiges Lernen
und die Freude am Spielen in einem.
Die Auswertung zeigt: Bei den Kids
ist einiges hängengeblieben.
Edy hat z.B. aufgeschrieben:
"Das waren Riffmantas."
Also keine Riesenmantas,
das stimmt.
Das waren alles Riffmantas. Es gibt
ja zwei verschiedene Spezies.
Das hat er richtig erkannt.
Und hier hat er aufgeschrieben,
dass eine der Flossen der Mantas
angebissen war.
Das hat auch gestimmt.
Das war eine der Verletzungen,
es hatte mehrere, aber das war eine.
Und so hat das jetzt jedes Kind
für sich aufgeschrieben.
Und das haben sie super gemacht.
Aufgabe sehr gut erfüllt.
Melando, wie viele Mantarochen
hast du gesehen?
Drei.
Hat jemand mehr gesehen?
- (Kinder) Nein.
Hat jemand weniger gesehen?
Also alle drei.
- (Kinder) Ja.
Sie hatten viel Freude daran,
die Mantas zu sehen.
Zumindest sagen sie nun,
dass keiner mehr Angst habe.
Ob es tatsächlich so ist,
wird sich zeigen,
wenn wir
wieder mal Mantas antreffen.
Aber es ist super,
wenn wir so weitermachen,
sehen sie mehr und mehr
die Schönheiten -
und wenn man die Schönheit
von etwas erkennt,
ist man auch viel mehr bereit,
etwas dafür zu machen
und das auch zu schützen.
Wie haben dir die Mantas gefallen?
- Schön!
Schön?
- Ja.
Glücklich? Happy?
- Ja. Yes.
Also das Strahlen ist ihnen
ins Gesicht geschrieben.
* Sanfte, abenteuerliche Klänge *
In Grönland ist es Ende März.
Die Landschaft in der Nähe des
Polarkreises ist prächtig anzusehen.
Sie ist geformt aus Schnee und Eis.
Das ist ganz nach dem Geschmack
des Zürcher Multimediajournalisten
Robert Hansen.
Für sein Hobby, das Eistauchen,
legt er weite Strecken zurück.
Aber bevor es so weit ist,
besucht er das Schlittenhunderennen,
das nur einmal im Jahr stattfindet.
* Bellen, Jaulen *
Es ist  d a s  Ereignis
für die Einheimischen -
und natürlich auch für die Touristen.
Wir haben auch einen kleinen Hund.
Der wartet zu Hause auf uns.
Einen kleinen Border Terrier.
Dem würde es hier auch gefallen,
aber man darf keine Hunde
mit nach Grönland nehmen.
Es ist strengstens verboten,
fremde Tiere einzuführen.
Auch Island
würde das nicht erlauben im Transit.
Ein schönes Tier.
Aber im Hochsommer
würde er bei uns leiden.
Nicht wahr, du?
Schlittenhunde werden ja hier in
Grönland als Arbeitstiere benutzt.
Es ist also nicht
irgendeine Touristenattraktion.
Hier jetzt einfach
der Wettbewerb untereinander,
wer der Schnellste ist.
Ein kleines Volksfest, Hunderte
von Leuten, die schauen kommen.
Wir haben viel Glück, dass wir
gerade jetzt hier stehen können -
und jetzt scheint es
gleich loszugehen.
* Sanfte, abenteuerliche Klänge *
Die Rennroute
führt über viele Kilometer,
entlang des gigantischen,
gefrorenen Fjords.
Für ein paar Stunden
vergessen die Einheimischen
ihren entbehrungsreichen Alltag.
Die meisten Inuit leben von der Jagd,
von den Geldspritzen Dänemarks
und vom aufkommenden Tourismus.
Das Rennen ist für den Multimedia-
journalisten ein ideales Sujet.
Er verfolgt es mit der Drohne.
Und wird damit selber zum Ereignis.
Nein, stell dich nicht davor!
* Applaus *
* Durchsage über Megafon
auf Grönländisch *
* Jubel, Applaus *
Dann gehen die Schlitten
in den Endspurt.
* Anfeuerungsrufe *
* Jubel *
Die Hunde freuen sich
auf frisches Robbenfleisch,
für sie eine Delikatesse.
* Jubel *
Dem Sieger winken Ruhm und Ehre -
und ein 3 m langer Schlitten
oder aber ein Gewehr -
er hat die Qual der Wahl.
* Jubel *
Für Haiforscherin Ornella Weideli
neigt sich die Zeit
auf den Seychellen dem Ende zu.
Bis im Frühling will die 32-Jährige
ihre Doktorarbeit über Junghaie
im Saint-Joseph-Atoll beendet haben.
Was dann kommt, ist noch offen.
Ich habe zwei Ziele für die Zukunft.
Eines professionell,
eines eher persönlich.
Professionell würde es mich
sehr freuen oder stark motivieren,
wenn ich etwas zum Schutz der Haie
beitragen könnte.
Ich kann natürlich nicht
alle Haie schützen,
aber vielleicht eine Art,
an einem Ort.
Hier in St. Joseph
haben wir das Glück,
dass sie hoffentlich
bald mal geschützt werden.
Aber es gibt andere Orte, wo
die Haie sehr stark gefährdet sind.
Vielleicht andere Gebiete,
wo die Jungen geboren werden,
dass ich dort mithelfen könnte,
dass sie dort geschützt sind.
Wenn ich mal alt bin,
kann ich zurückschauen und sagen:
"Hier konnte ich mithelfen."
Ich will etwas Grosses erreichen,
nicht nur
einen Acht-bis-Fünf-Job machen.
Das ist für mich
sowieso nicht möglich.
Und persönlich: Ich will einfach
glücklich sein, ganz einfach,
und Freude haben am Leben
und nicht genau wissen,
was am nächsten Tag passiert.
Einfach das Leben geniessen
und sehen, wie schön die Natur ist.
Und die Schönheit des Lebens sehen.
Ungewissheit
beinhaltet auch Freiheit.
Und die ist Ornella wichtig.
Auch im Privatleben.
Darum will sie diese Zeit geniessen,
gemeinsam mit ihren Freunden
aus der ganzen Welt.
Cheers, Darnsley.
- Cheers.
Cheers.
Ich glaube, wenn man nicht im Moment
lebt, verpasst man so viel.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
heutzutage denken viele Leute schon,
was in zehn Jahren ist.
Dann fangen sie schon an zu planen,
da Kinder und da ein Haus
und da sparen für das.
Und dann vergisst man
vielleicht auch,
wie schön es im Moment sein kann.
Ich glaube auch, auf solchen Inseln
mit Leuten zusammenzuarbeiten,
die anders aufgewachsen sind,
mit Darnsley und so,
lernt man auch
einen etwas anderen Lebensstil,
und man passt sich einander auch an.
Das tut auch wieder gut.
Ornella Weidelis Geschichte beweist,
dass es möglich ist,
seinen Traum zu leben.
Denn eine Haiforscherin aus
einem Land ohne Meer hat den Mut,
nach den Sternen zu greifen.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Nach dem Hundeschlittenrennen
hofft Robert Hansen,
dass ein lang gehegter Wunsch
endlich Wirklichkeit wird.
Denn ein solcher Eisberg erwärmt
das Herz eines jeden Kalttauchers.
Das Eis ist hart wie Stahl und weist
die verschiedensten Blautöne auf.
Flut und Ebbe lassen das Wasser
mit dem Eis um den Berg
sich anheben und senken.
Allein das ist ein Spektakel.
Du musst
noch ein wenig weiter zurück!
Seit fünf Jahren
reist Robert ans Polarmeer,
seine Frau Renee
begleitet ihn so oft wie möglich.
Man braucht viel Geduld.
Bis er seine ganzen sieben Sachen
eingepackt und ausgepackt hat
und die Drohne wieder verpackt hat
und wieder ausgepackt hat.
Aber man wird reichlich belohnt
für die Geduld.
Mit solchen Reisen
und solchen Orten,
an die man kommt auf dieser Welt,
das ist wirklich schön,
das ist schön.
Unter Wasser, das ist eines, da bin
ich auch gerne alleine unterwegs.
Aber über Wasser natürlich nicht.
Denn da kann man so eine Landschaft,
so eine Gegend, so ein Land
auch miteinander geniessen und
auch gemeinsame Erlebnisse teilen.
Das Eis beim Einstiegsloch ist dünn,
anders als beim letzten Mal,
als sich die Eisschichten
entlang des Ufers
meterdick übereinander gelegt hatten.
Aber diese Eislandschaft
ist vergänglich,
die Folgen des Klimawandels
werden immer gravierender.
Das bekommt Roberts Expeditionsleiter
Sven Gust hautnah mit.
Man sieht schon,
dass die Gletscher in erschreckender
Geschwindigkeit abschmelzen.
Die Auswirkungen davon, die lassen
noch etwas auf sich warten,
aber wir sehen tatsächlich,
dass Tierarten hier zu finden sind -
sprich Wale,
z.B. Pottwale und Pilotwale -,
die wir hier früher
gar nicht gesichtet haben.
Die sind jetzt im Sommer
Normalität geworden.
Das hat sich
innerhalb der zehn Jahre -
es sind wirklich nur zehn Jahre,
wo ich das hier kenne -
schon sehr, sehr verändert.
Wie immer beim Eistauchen
ist die Vorbereitung wichtig,
denn im eisigen Wasser muss
alles einwandfrei funktionieren.
40 kg Gepäck am Rücken,
ein schwerer Rucksack.
Das ist mir eine Nummer zu kräftig.
Nein, nein, die Vorstellung,
das Eis über dem Kopf zu haben,
ist nicht so angenehm.
Und nur ein kleines Loch,
aus dem man wieder herauskommt,
das wäre nicht mein Ding.
Robert braucht eine dicke Haut
für die Minustemperaturen.
Aber um sich einen Lebenstraum zu
erfüllen, nimmt er all das in Kauf.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
... v.a. wenn du drehst.
Lieber andersrum drehen.
* Sanfte, abenteuerliche Klänge *
Raja Ampat bedeutet frei übersetzt so
viel wie "das Reich der vier Könige".
1'500 Inseln gehören
zu dieser Gegend in Indonesien.
Um dieses Naturparadies zu bewahren,
hat Jonas zusammen mit Einheimischen
eine NGO gegründet.
Sie heisst Child Aid Papua.
Heute hat der Glarner mit seinen
Schülern etwas ganz Besonderes vor.
Er fährt mit ihnen
zu einem geheimnisumwitterten Ort.
Das Abenteuer
beginnt schon bei der Anfahrt.
* Sanfte, angespannte Klänge *
Wir sind hier an einem
wunderschönen Ort in Raja Ampat.
Ich möchte den Ort nicht verraten.
Es ist einer der Orte,
die zum Glück vom Tourismus
noch nicht entdeckt worden sind.
Darum ist es wunderschön,
wenn man hier alleine hinfahren
und den Kindern die Schönheit der
Natur von Raja Ampat zeigen kann.
Über diesen abgelegenen Ort
wird Unheimliches gemunkelt.
Es ist für sie sicher einer
der Orte, von denen sie meinen ...
Es gibt auch eine Drachenhöhle.
Sie glauben, da wohne ein Drache,
und man könne
seine Augen leuchten sehen.
Also Raja Ampat und die Tribes,
die hier wohnen,
sind natürlich voll
von solchen Mythen,
an die sie noch stark glauben.
Jonas will den Kindern,
die ihre Insel nur selten verlassen,
die Drachenhöhle zeigen -
aber es gibt ein Problem.
Es geht darum,
das Boot schlau anzubinden,
wenn wir jetzt alle weggehen.
Denn es bleibt bestimmt
niemand alleine beim Boot,
weil sie viel zu sehr Angst hätten
vor irgendwelchen Geistern.
Jetzt müssen wir
das Boot gut anmachen,
damit es auch noch hier ist,
wenn wir zurückkommen.
Seit Generationen
erzählt man sich Schauergeschichten.
Die sind ganz unterschiedlich.
Es geht von Geistern, Spirits,
die da sind, von denen sie glauben,
dass die kommen
und ihnen die Köpfe abhacken.
Dann sind es Geister, wie wir sie
kennen, wie der Teufel z.B.
Da haben sie das Gefühl, dass der
hier irgendwo wartet und Spuk macht.
Jetzt hier bei der Drachenhöhle
spezifisch der Drachen selber.
Okay, hört zu! Wir gehen jetzt rauf.
Aber denkt dran, ihr dürft nie
zu nah am Abgrund gehen,
sonst fallt ihr hinunter.
Bleibt immer schön vom Rand weg!
Okay, let's go.
* Sphärische Klänge *
In Grönland taucht Robert Hansen
in eine Wasserwelt voller Wunder ein.
Die Temperatur beträgt -3 °C.
Das Salz verhindert,
dass das Meerwasser gefriert.
Der Eisberg
gleicht einer gewaltigen Skulptur.
Mal sind die Konturen weich und rund,
dann sind sie wiederum
kantig und messerscharf.
* Sphärische Klänge *
Bis in 20 m Tiefe kann Robert
den Eisberg auskundschaften.
* Sphärische Klänge *
In diesem nährstoffreichen Wasser
gedeihen überraschend viele Pflanzen.
Die braunen Kelp-Blätter
beherbergen zahlreiche Tiere,
wie den Skorpionfisch.
* Sphärische Klänge *
Über Wasser
haben sich diese Eiszapfen gebildet.
Weil die Flut
den Wasserspiegel anhebt,
sind sie nun für Robert
unter Wasser sichtbar.
Robert ist hochkonzentriert
und vergisst alles um sich herum.
* Sphärische Klänge *
Aber nach 75 Min. ist Schluss,
die Kälte wird bedrohlich.
Robert hat schon
über 500 Tauchgänge gemacht,
aber dieses Mal
war es intensiver als alles,
was er bisher erlebt hat.
Das werde ich nie mehr so erleben.
Das war so schön.
Es war einfach magisch.
* Zufriedenes Ausatmen *
* Ausatmen *
Und am Schluss der Sonnenstrahl,
der da reingeschienen hat, so schön.
So schön.
Vielleicht sind es
solche überwältigende Momente,
die uns Menschen Demut lehren
und uns daran erinnern,
Sorge zu tragen
zur einzigen Erde, die wir haben.
So, jetzt sind wir gleich oben,
bei der Drachenhöhle.
* Lachen *
Umweltlehrer Jonas Müller
zeigt den Kindern von Raja Ampat
eine unbekannte Welt.
Die sagenumwobene Drachenhöhle.
Jetzt sieht man, dass sie sich ...
Ehm ...
Also wenn man ein Land neu betritt,
streicht man sich
die Erde an die Stirne.
Man bittet so die Geister,
die hier wohnen, um Erlaubnis,
dass man das betreten darf und
mit guten Absichten hierherkommt.
Das ist ein Zeichen dafür.
Es geht darum, dass die Geistern
einen nicht krank machen.
* Hohe Pfeifgeräusche *
Wo ist der Drache?
- Da unten.
Kommt er zu uns rauf?
Kann er fliegen?
Kann er Feuer spucken?
Sie erzählten gerade,
dass der Drachen hier unten wohnt.
Also er geht runter
und dort hat er seine Höhle.
Und natürlich kann er Feuer spucken.
Und darum sieht man auch
seine Krallenabdrücke dort oben.
Die sind vom Drachen,
wenn er böse ist.
Sie haben eine Riesenfreude,
hier zu sein,
aber auch gemischte Gefühle.
Einerseits Freude,
andererseits Respekt, Angst,
es ist auch ein neuer Ort.
Ich denke,
es ist eine gute Erfahrung,
die die Kinder machen können.
* Jonas spricht indonesisch. *
Also Melando meint,
er habe schon einmal
das Feuer des Drachens gesehen.
Er habe gesehen,
wie der Drache Feuer gespuckt habe.
* Sie sprechen indonesisch. *
Aber nicht hier,
anscheinend flog der Drache etwas
weiter weg, und er sah es von dort.
Aber er meint,
es sei der Drachen von hier gewesen.
Jonas respektiert
die Sagenwelt der Einheimischen.
Ich finde, ich muss sie nicht
von ihrem Glauben abbringen.
Ich finde, das ist schön,
das gehört zu ihnen.
Das Einzige, was ich mache:
Ich stelle meine Fragen dazu.
Ich kann sie damit
ein wenig zum Nachdenken anregen.
Und z.T. - je nach Geschichte -
merken sie selber:
Das macht jetzt keinen Sinn.
Und gewisse Geschichten bleiben so,
und das ist auch völlig okay.
Sie sollen
ihre Geschichten hier haben,
das macht das Ganze hier
viel interessanter.
Okay, let's go!
- Let's go!
* Rassige Ukulele-Klänge *
* Gesang auf Indonesisch *
Man darf nicht meinen,
man könne die Welt retten oder so.
Aber ich kann den Kindern
viel mitgeben,
damit sie
mit dem Verständnis aufwachsen,
dass sie mal in einer Position sind,
in der sie auch
den richtigen Hebel ziehen können
für Raja Ampat.
Das ist eigentlich
mein täglicher Antrieb.
* Sanfter Kindergesang
auf Indonesisch *